gilbert avec un sigle est là je crois
que là on va porter les dieux on verra
c'est qu'il l'aura mercredi soir aussi
une affaire big noise la neige non moi
je comprends pas l'idée de deux souffert
en fait mais c'est super oc cesson vie
qu'ils ont de très près par tour là oui
mais c'est ce qu'on savait mais c'est
moche enfin les décors ce qu'il y ait si
la fouine autour de la table c'était
celui ci que j'avais des idées
ouais je trouve ça juste qu'on se trouve
ça dégueulasse voyez que j'ai bien fait
lui dire
[Applaudissements]
dix suisses il n'y a rien à dire qu'ils
soient pour ou de je sais pas c'est
bizarre bien trop de quoi il sera à
donetsk bizarre mais qu'est ce tu veux
qu'on polémique 200 ans sur ce sujet la
famille des simpson allez on va passer à
l'extravagance de la semaine